Marcelo Bielsa can count Pep Guardiola
Mauricio Pacino and until yesterday
Frank Lampard amongst his many admirers
but his reputation faces being tarnished
by Spygate
a concerned member of the public called
police to Derby County's Academy when
they spotted someone acting suspiciously
near one of its fences during a training
session the Leeds manager has since
admitted he's and a spy not attractive
occasionally I understand the situation
if it's not allowed in English football
I have to accept it because I work here
but for me it is hard to agree that my
behavior was unacceptable
it may not be common practice here but
it does not make me achieve them in as
supporters made light of the situation
Leeds went on to win last night's game
two nil to put them five points clear at
the top of the championship table at
least on a sport sportsmen level it's
bad in my opinion if we're going to
start talking about culturally I did it
somewhere else and it was fine then that
doesn't work for me because I don't
believe it is fine on that level the
Argentinian once called the world's
greatest coach by Guardiola says he's
done this for years and it's in South
America it's no big deal
a coach has to know his own scene but
also he has to know the opposition so
he's gonna want to glean as much
information about the Opposition as
possible now there aren't seem to be any
specific laws ruling out what Bielsa and
members of his coaching staff have done
on this occasion Leeds of today issued a
statement saying following comments made
by marcelo bielsa yesterday the club
will look to work with our head coach
and his staff to remind them of the
integrity and honesty which are the
foundations that Leeds United is built
on our owner
andraia robert sony has met with Derby
County's owner Mel Morris to formally
apologize for Marcelo's actions Derby
fans are pretty clear on whether this is
gamesmanship or cheating there's no law
against it but I think it's right treat
him
definitely you wouldn't need to send
someone an ass it was cheated not
allowed spying teams what do you think
should be done free much fun former
Derby manager Brian Clough during his a
very brief tenure as Leeds United
manager once famously told the players
they could put all their medals and
trophies in the bin because as far as he
was concerned they'd won them by
cheating one can only imagine what
Clough II would have made of Spygate the
FA say they are aware of the incident at
the training ground and will be
investigating the matter but with no
real precedence it's unclear whether any
punishment can or will be handed out and
if it is whether it will be directed
towards the club or its manager Fraser
Maud Sky News Derby